The Joe Rogan experience.
So we're going to be in Chicago for that big fight.
Fuck it.
Oh,
how would I was going to be fine.
What does that June mm,
what does that,
June 8th,
right?
June 8th.
Right now I don't,
I don't think there's any tickets left.
If anybody wants to know.
I doubt it pretty close.
But there's a,
that's a big UFC car too,
isn't it?
Who's on that car?
Uh,
I just saw this morning,
I just looked this morning.
Henry pseudo versus a Marlin Mariah's for the bantamweight title.
Ooh.
She has the opportunity to become champ champ.
And then I'm Ma Marlin rise.
Fucking fantastic fighter.
Yeah,
that's a great card.
She me Rivera and Petra Yawn.
Yawn.
Pyotr I think you're suppose to say peel truck to pure tra.
Pure tro Russian character.
Valentino of changeovers.
Jessica.
I,
that's great fight too.
That's such a great name.
Stuff.
Chanko yeah.
Such a great fucking Badass.
I fuck you up.
Name that.
Hold on.
Stop scrolling back up.
It's Tatiana Suarez is a beast to,
that woman is so good.
She's probably the best wrestler in female MMA.
She smashes people and Nita and Sar off is fantastic.
That's a great fight.
That's um,
Amanda Nunez.
His girlfriend too.
Amanda Nunez is probably the baddest woman,
literally ever.
And we met her,
right?
Yeah,
she was at the last,
she's the one who knocked out Cyborg.
Cyborg was the baddest woman in MMA when Amanda knew at Nunez starched her in
the first round.
There's no one you could literally legitimately give that title too.
It's Amanda Nunez.
She is the baddest woman ever.
Aljamain sterling versus page on windows.
That's a gray card.
Ricardo Lamas.
Calvin,
Kate,
or that's a great fight to shit.
A lot of,
a lot of chicks,
a lot of checks be fighting.
A lot of Chicago girls saying,
go,
go girls getting ready,
getting ready to fly.
Tam fucking tie in this town.
That's you guys.
That's Boston.
Chicago girls are more,
I don't know how to say the Chicago and Chicago's,
she
can kiss my ass.
I'll fuck you up.